first of all who is that in your arms
this is henry henry you gotta say hi
let's say hi to drew
and how old is henry henry is almost 12
years old
henry is so cute so my dog douglas here
he's
almost 12. and then my dog lucy here
is gonna be seven and so when douglas
had lucy walk into his life it was like
claudia schiffer walking into his life
so he's
he's a happy guy and this is jeremy um
who's a girl
but she's a bearded dragon anyway it's
not always tough
it's not always easy to tell with those
guys but i love that you're a reptile
fan
the reptiles are what kind of initially
got my heart with animals
at a very young age and i'm i just love
working with them and i love them
well when i saw the cover of your book
that cover
is so eye-catching it is so bold
i mean it is a bam it is sexy it's like
real oh thank you you're making me blush
over here
um will you please tell us about the
book it's me in my early adulthood life
i guess where i am
a wildlife enthusiast and i am so keen
to just get out into the wild into the
natural habitats where my favorite
species are native to around the world
and that's places like australia and
africa and southeast asia central
america
and basically it's an evolution of that
kind of work and travel into becoming a
veterinarian and being a vet and getting
to do real veterinary work and real
conservation work and work with amazing
conservationists and vets
and wildlife rescues around the world
and getting to share my story and the
crazy travels and
there's happy moments and exciting
moments and scary moments and sad
moments and
funny moments and everything in between
when you were shooting the cover of your
book
did you bring in like inspiration
pictures was there like a nice calvin
klein shot
like you are giving it in this picture
it is it is
like world wild vet is like oh my gosh
it's so striking yeah i know i love that
picture and yeah
i just i went online and i googled just
men holding giant lizards on their
shoulders and i found so many great
pictures
and no no i'm kidding it uh it just it
just happened and the photographer is
awesome i loved working with him
and um we had a lot of great shots from
that day and that lizard is that was a
very sweet uh
asian water monitor lizard and she was
just cooperative and i just
i just i don't know i thought it'd be a
fun idea honestly and i just we were
just kind of playing with it it turned
out to get you know we got some good
shots
you know my daughter olive her nickname
is ace ventura because she has that gift
she has the gift with animals and she's
obsessed with them and she wants to be a
veterinarian
do you have any advice for her you know
i think
my biggest advice would be just as much
for you and that's just to cultivate
that you know get her books and shows
and help her learn and take her on you
know to the zoo
a good zoos and good trips and things
like that to get her exposed and
and just really feed that interest of
hers dr evan anton we have a question
for you would it be okay
quianna you have a question for the
wonderful dr
evan anton yes hi there
so hi how are you doing i'm good
this is cupcake here um and as you can
see she's super tiny only about five
pounds and every time she goes for her
pack up she's that same weight but she
eats so much like she's always hungry
why is that you know that's a common
thing in dogs and henry to be honest is
the same way
i've got a little dog too and this guy
will eat until i stop
feeding him so i have to be really
careful with that and it's really our
metabolism
works very similar to that of dogs and
that it all comes down to you know how
many calories are coming in and how many
calories are being burned at the end of
the day
and for dogs if they're not as active
and they're kind of couch potatoes like
henry is very guilty of and i'm guilty
of
of basically facilitating that um you
know it's easy for them to gain weight
and many dogs have high appetites and
then neutering and spaying dogs which i
highly
encourage for most dogs is uh is
something that can actually slow down
the metabolism
and it can increase the appetite both
things are kind of a recipe for gaining
weight
and so when you know all those things
the key to it is just make sure you're
feeding the appropriate amount for your
pet
and you know try to get them activity
and exercise if they're healthy enough
to do so
well i love what you do i've followed
you for a long time
and i think whether it's you on the
cover of your book
you know the person that you are that
shines through
you help you know keep humans interested
in what's the responsible thing to do
with
animals and our planets and i really
thank you for everything that you do
oh that means so much if that's your
takeaway from this book that's
everything that's that makes me so happy
to hear and that's exactly what i would
love for readers to get from it so that
those words mean a lot drew thank you
very much
you